نعم اهلا بك ميسون مره اخرى العربيه تواكب
مغادره وكذلك وصول عمليات الاجلاء وكذلك
مغادرتهم سواء من الموانع التي حدثتها
السعوديه وكذلك من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه التي نتواجد فيها الان
في هذه اللحظات يصل وفد او الدفعه الاولى
من بعثه الامم المتحده التي وصلت اليوم
عبر سفينه امانا وهي وصلت الان الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه استعدادا لمغادرتها
عموما سوف يكون ضيفي الاستاذ محمد الغنيم
وهو ممثل في الامم المتحده مرحبا بك استاذ
محمد على شاشه العربيه بينما نطرح عليك
السؤال في هذه اللحظات وايضا بعدها كاميرا
العربيه سوف تتجول على البيئه التي وصلت
دعنا نتحدث عن العدد الذي وصل الان واين
سيذهب والمرحله المقبله بالنسبه لهم
حاليا هذا
الخطوه او القسم الثاني من عمليه الاخلاق
المتفق عليها مع مقام وزاره الخارجيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعددهم مياه 151 تقريبا
تم اجلائهم بسفينه امانه من ميناء بور
السودان الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
وتم نقلهم الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه حيث سيتم تجهيز طائره
لهم
خلال الدقائق القادمه
وسينتقلون ان شاء الله الى دوله كينيا
مدينه نيروبي ومنها سيكون هناك اتصال
للرحله الى
الى دوله اوغندا طيب اولا دعنا نتعرف عن
هذه الطائره ما هي نوعيه الطائره هل هي
طائره تجاريه من طائره خاصه بالامم
المتحده
وللمذا تحديدا
نيروبي يعني
هي طائره
طائرهم متعاقده مع
طقمها
بالنسبه
للجزء في سؤالك لماذا نيروبي بانه
بعد احداث السودان هي دوله كينيا وعاصمتها
نور نيروبي
وتم اعداد الخطه مع
[موسيقى]
المقام وزاره الخارجيه بهذا الشان هل ما
زال هناك عالقين بالنسبه لاعضاء الهمم
المتحده في السودان ام جميعهم وصلوا الى
جده وكذلك تم اجلائهم
بفضل الله ثم بفضل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بشكل سريع من قبل الجوازات السعوديه تماما
للمرحله التي بعدها التي سوف يغادرون الى
نيروبي
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات